44 seconds for two logos which with
these two studios is par for the course
still simple as hell Castle lamp
lettering boom you're done in ten
seconds if you have no ego discount or
you start a boom Farkus she's a lady
movie has conflicting emotions about
gender equality in a span of two seconds
damn how bad was her reign movie expects
me to believe that this arrow shot went
that deep into the woods movie barely
cracks the 3-minute mark before
introducing magic magic the lord of
allmovie ex machina s' follow me now
child then your mother will become a
bear later willow the wisp Reese's
Pieces you know some say that willow the
wisps lead you to your feet others say
they just waste your time making you
prance wildly around the forest but
everyone agrees that they exist which is
a bull this giant-ass bear somehow snuck
up on everyone who he thinks we are
fooled that Fergus died by cutting away
at the last second some see our destiny
is tied to the narration the story of
how my father lost his leg to the demon
bear mordioux bikini legend and
therefore we didn't bother to animate it
or show it to you it was too legendary I
can never get away with anything that's
because you're eating an apple and you
look like an asshole
in what way did she think this was
private also she takes one bite and then
throws it on the ground at least leave
it intact so it doesn't get all rotten
why did she bring this Apple in the
first place if you remove all the murder
and rape Merida is also kind of a
discount ancestor holy crap now she's
stealing apples and she's a princess so
nobody can say anything so that's double
asshole duty in two minutes she sure can
ride a horse out of the castle into the
wilderness but can she bait with all the
colors of the wind huh huh
so basically badass Maid Marian or stop
what the hell is she doing a Tom Cruise
impression or is it actually happening
right now I don't really know prevented
her from falling to her death but thank
God for an unusually strong grip that
can stop falling momentum awesome now
what how do you even get down three
Apple teens in four minutes this is an
orgy of evidence that this movie was
made for cinemas in six months before we
existed I won't die with that cat huh an
arranged marriage in a Disney movie
that's par for the course actually so
sin for repetition
he divided the kingdom among his four
sons one who is obviously evil because
he's in the shadows and has demon eyes
also and this is totally racist the bad
brother is represented by the black
chess piece followed his own path and
the kingdom fell seriously the message
here is that he followed his own path
and that's the reason why Merida can't
shy away from tradition what about the
clearly more important part of the story
where the guy was power-hungry and
obviously an evil guy but as married are
gonna bring up this point hell no I
swear I guess this isn't going to happen
not five any C in it but you and
everyone else in this movie have gone
out of their way to show me how much you
do not have a seat near the family you
worry about but turn out to not be that
important to the story after all they're
the family that will eventually lose to
the well-regarded pentium clan and
here's the I can't breathe cliche as
seen in all the movies where the plucky
young heroine puts on restrictive
clothing and doesn't want to marry
whomever it is they're being offered so
we're supposed to think the awesome
muscular guy is this dude son but his
son is standing behind that guy and my
only question is why is the strong
awesome guy standing so proudly in front
of the crowd if he's not the dude son
this King has a slippery grip on his
subjects titty twisters now this movie
is doing nothing to improve the
reputation of Scottish folk not that it
claimed to be or anything but still
drinks and fights a lot check I choose
archery the princess declared archery
would be the contest of choice so what's
the screen long tossing going on for 23
minutes in and these kids have
absolutely zero good qualities they are
terrible what a bastard drop it also
these kids went through all this trouble
to steal pastries when there are about a
hundred different ways that didn't
involve climbing a tent and swooping
down to get them Merida thinks this plan
is going to work as if Scottish lawn
stealin loopholes as ludicrous as this
yep Pixar is now stooping to Hey look at
my hairy asshole moments for humour this
is probably as blunt of a masturbation
metaphor as it gets also super sexist
ancient male-dominated society just lets
her do this this is probably as blunt of
an emasculation metaphor as it gets do
you bother to ask what I want this whole
script so far basically comes from the
dusty blueprint of rebel without a cause
honestly as valid as the conflict is in
this movie it just comes off worn out
luckily for this blunt metaphor the
picture was drawn in such a way that the
divide between mother and daughter is
easy to slice a sword through
overbearing parent literally destroys
child's precious thingamajig cliche mom
feels guilty about burning Merida's beau
roughly eight seconds after angrily
throwing said bow into the fireplace
it's movies moving fast at least
emotionally trying keep up okay how is
the recent betrothed and sobbing
princess allowed to leave the castle
without anyone trying to stop her or
telling her dead or even
written note of her exit discount
Stonehenge these bright blue forest
lights are basically Merida's video game
prompts also this is some air-traffic
controller type magic lighting the magic
bandit must be half GPS apparently
Merida has never heard the story of the
big bad wolf also discount power pellets
without any evidence or proof Merida
keeps following these things deeper and
deeper into the creepy forest
I think the wisps leave me here I don't
know maybe because of the mysterious
house in the woods and man you are super
trusting a possibly evil creatures in
the forest aren't you
Merida doesn't immediately run out of
the creepy wood carving Hut Fantasia
brews Fantasia Toy Story Pizza Planet
truck Easter Egg makes no goddamn sense
in this ancient reality you couldn't
find a single Pixar character whose
cameo would make more sense in this time
period like Rex really a god damn pickup
truck 2,000 years before trucks were
invented I'm surprised how upset this
makes me see what you're doing how could
she possibly know what she's doing she
stumbled into a witch hut in the forest
and instantly asked for a spell she's
the very definition of no idea what
she's doing this witch's brew has
somehow produced a perfectly cooked
fruit pastry from a cauldron of bubbling
acid and I've seen enough Top Chef to
know that this is some Bulls beer yeah
sure if I give this to my mom
it will change my fate why is it that
when these characters in these types of
stories get a wish or something they ask
for the vagus possible wish open for
interpretation changing your fate could
literally mean all outcomes positive and
negative but don't involve marrying the
three dumb asses at the archery
competition hang up the scale did you
say something for no reason the witch
completely disappears before she can
remember an important thing about the
spell doesn't she have control over
whether she disappears are the wisps
responsible there was this house and
which created by a fairy godmother spell
that expires after midnight you made
this for me
I don't know mom seems awfully trusting
of her rebellious daughter after the Chi
poll today did nervous mom really just
turn into a bear because that is not the
movie I signed up for I know she said I
want a spell to change my mom but that
was frightening lis vague and contained
no mention of bears also if you're
wondering why this Pixar original didn't
connect with you like you thought it
might look no further than the story
which sets up this badass independent
woman as a Terran and gives her nothing
to do except clean up the mess she
started also and they finally did it
Disney remade Brother Bear and made it
into mother bear weight just to blame
but actually you know even though she's
seen the shadow and saw her clones and
all things pointing to being a bear the
is what sent her into a surprised frenzy
of destruction it's funny her mom is
still trying to be proven proper even as
a bear but I'm shocked she's not
concerned about her safety right now
what's worse that this guy can smell a
white bear at over 500 kilometres or
that said white bear doesn't realize
this and get the kind of dodge as soon
as she realizes she's a goddamn bear you
can have my deserts for two weeks how
are these kids not insanely fat at this
point don't give me that kid metabolism
nonsense either these kids steal
hundreds of pastries a day the idea that
a bear ground can be made this way and a
chicken on a stick even comes close to
looking with the shadow of a bear talk
to the bear hand I find it I can't
either
since this stupid place disappeared
completely in the last scene and now
it's reappeared for no reason other than
to give you hope through Goldberg ex
machina one bit I forgot to tell you
about despair yeah there really was no
way I could just hang around for five
more seconds or leave you a note that
didn't require a Rube Goldberg
contraption one more time feet be
changed
seriously this couldn't be written down
magically etched in stone welcome to the
crafty Carver what remember when the
witch did this earlier she went through
three choices one ending with if you're
that red-haired girl use file three but
instead of waiting for that Merida
panics and throws all the potions into
the cauldron because she's a dick also
despite the fact that Merida too screwed
herself anyway couldn't the witch have
left a few more vials of number three
just in case she needed to hear that
message again how is that crown still on
her damn bear head
help should have fallen off and gotten
lost as soon as she went into bear mode
look either there's enough room to hide
from the rain or there isn't don't show
me a structure that seems to have all
the room and then show me two
protagonists camped out on the edge to
where they're both getting rained on a
ton I mean move back ten inches Jesus
I'll always be right here
even if I'm a bear this fire is the
exact same fire in the fireplace from
earlier a princess should not have
weapons in your opinion Merida tries to
teach her mom a lesson about how it's
good for a princess to have weapons in a
situation where they both are in this
mess because of her in the first place
yep her mom is still a bear just popping
in to clarify that continued apparent
fact the Bears even like their fish
cooked I can't imagine why or how or why
they would considering they can't start
fires I know this particular bearer used
to be human but is there no bear inside
there at all three sins in one here she
thinks bears fish just by opening their
mouths
this fish jumps directly into her not
moving open mouth and she spits it out
like it's girls lady you are a bear now
with the program yes what every icy
mother-daughter relationship really
needs is for one of them to be turned
into a bear and face the hardships of
salmon fishing mom's full transition to
a wild bear happened really fast because
I just saw a montage of her romping with
her human daughter for like five minutes
and now this
I thought she had until the second
sunrise Theo show us the way will they
really though they showed you the way to
the witch's house earlier and I just
turned into a disaster why do you even
trust these assholes isn't it nice that
these ruins have a perfectly placed pile
of rocks so that if you fall through the
floor won't kill you but even hurt you
rock depicting the story Eleanor told
Merida just happens to have a split
between the good brothers and the bad
brother lit like the tapestry I know the
parallels between that story and your
story are crazy similar the Speyer
waited until marital earned everything
before coming in to attack unlikely also
can we just go ahead and say the wisps
are the antagonist of this movie they
are not kind they're not helpful and
they're total assholes these clans have
been shooting at each other for what
appears to be well long enough to shoot
a hundred arrows into each of all these
tables and no one is dead I will say
that this dude catching an arrow is
hilarious he's the best character in the
movie because he's clearly above it all
we'd remove uh sin but the sin is that
he's not in and enough sure many of
these clans are facing away from the big
giant bear walking behind them but
Fergus and everyone else are facing
toward the bear and somehow miss her
completely and Jesus does no one see
this for are we going on that is a lot
of curry also somehow all this works
Merida says we should love whom we want
and everyone beholden to these Scottish
traditions just says okay well at least
we got to play some pointless games
after sailing all this way just new Fiat
Marcus this guy is harder to understand
that Ennis Delmont Eleanor's bear-like
tendencies show up when the plot needs
it too funny how it didn't happen once
while Merida was making her plea to the
clans no domestic violence the best way
to keep your daughter safe is to lock
her up cliche triplet bears ex machina
get the key these assholes have been
barriers almost as long as Eleanor ass
but never did anything bear like or
turned into real bears or anything
remotely close to anything that matters
to this story one of the many talents
Merida possesses is sewing while riding
on a horse in the rain we didn't see her
honing these skills earlier but we must
assume that she did also by the way this
whole thing is solved by sewing the
tapestry back together it did not
require sneaking Eleanor back into the
castle at all this movie's resolution
could happen ten minutes ago this is the
first time the wisps have ever done
anything useful
King is a dick to his daughter I mean
despair he doesn't realize as his wife
is completely restrained right now why
does he need to violently shove his
daughter out of the picture mordioux
prefers the knock people as far away as
possible method of fighting as opposed
to using his claws to destroy them
mordioux finds a way to taunt Merida
instead of revenant in her ass when this
movie started if you'd have told me it
was going to end with a human bear and a
bear bear brawling and rip off
Stonehenge arena I'd have flipped you
off and not even watch this so sin for
you for not telling me that before I
watch this movie none of these onlookers
try to assist in the takedown of
mordioux because they're all little
bitches the deadline of the second
sunrise is apparently set up to be when
the light reaches the bottom of the East
stones which is some horse you know what
I would have enjoyed more a movie about
a strong-willed Scottish princess
refusing to get married by parental
arrangement that contained no magic
mother bear's we saw absolutely nothing
that changed from the moment Mayor to
put the tapestry on her mom to the time
of the second sunrise other than her
crime which means that this is a
supercalifragilistic expialidocious
asshole of a curse to tease this family
like this
he changed oh darling we both have well
no actually Merida got everything she
wanted without changing a bit make it
well no actually you have a tapestry
wrapped around me I mean I kind of get
it in all but stop saying things that
are true yeah that seems like the
perfect match Maudie the most annoying
character in the movie gets the awesome
warrior dude in the end makes sense
there are those who say feet is
something beyond our command and those
people are correct our feet lives within
us you only have to be brave enough to
see it you can't sneak a roll credits
pass me assholes also I guess she was
indeed brave but that doesn't mean you
didn't steal this title from Braveheart
which was also about Scottish people
fighting for freedom and whose heroes
mom memorably turned into a bear if you
remember don't you on that you thieving
jerks this wisp is still an asshole
Tibbits no Scottish it's crap
I bring you peace like when you love
some see our destiny is tied to the land
just now
how do you solve the problem like Maria
how do you catch a cloud and pin it down
the bunny scared Mike the bunny scared
of you and you got your pain catchers
inside a cause of these Lang's man
you're looking at your colors and
looking at your fangs you're thinking to
yourself I don't know what to do man I
don't know how to kill the bunny they
can afford time out for this is the
fishing season all they have to do is
wait I saw him Kanda